state-of-the-art bag sorting automated
security Lanes
and something I rarely experienced at an
airport
it's really quiet
SFO just won wsj's best airport of 2022
and I'm here to see why so I toured the
airport's newest space the 2.5 billion
dollar Harvey Milk terminal 1. to test
out the amenities and go and check out
the logistics that helped SFO beat its
closest competition Minneapolis and
Atlanta
we'll start behind the scenes let's do
it
this is Ivar cetero he's the airport
director here and my tour guide for the
day
okay come on thank you
so we are in the back system underneath
at Harvey Milk terminal one this is the
zone between when you drop your bag off
at check-in and when your bag gets on
whatever plane you're taking out of SFO
exactly this tote-based baggage system
is the first of its kind in the U.S and
SFO says it's helping to smooth the
airport's operations basically every bag
is paired with one of these white bins
or totes each with their own unique
identifying number which allows the bag
in the tote to be more easily tracked
along its Journey here we have the um
the totes coming out and the bags are
dropping into the totes this system can
move up to 450 bags per minute that's
more than twice that of a traditional
conveyor system and SFO says it gets
backed up less often than other baggage
systems too for travelers I mean it just
you know increases the chances that your
bag is going to get to and from the
plane
as you hope I sat down with my colleague
wsj columnist Don Gilbertson who spends
a lot of time thinking about the
traveler experience after the nightmare
summer a lot of Travelers had with lost
luggage uh it's it's a bonus but equally
as important as how an airport routes
bags is how it moves people terminal 1's
layout helps with that just look at its
eight automated security Lanes they are
both wider and longer than others in the
airport and you can see there's this
island here and so you can really just
take your tray and move over the island
and give someone else an opportunity to
see their bag but if that's not enough
space to tie your shoes SFO has this 11
000 square foot space it calls the
recompose area that's just a fancy way
of saying post-security SFO sees this
space as a place where Travelers can
reset dare I say relax before venturing
to their Gates and soon any traveler
could enter through Terminal 1 because
SFO is working to connect all terminals
post security we're excited about
finishing the last phase of Harvey Milk
terminal one which will then complete
the Horseshoe of our terminal complex
that means Travelers connecting here
won't have to exit and go back through
another checkpoint just to make their
next flight right now though Terminal 1
is only connected to part of the
international terminal those logistical
upgrades are aimed at making travel
easier but to score high in our rankings
SFO also had to provide the amenities
Travelers want sure there's free Wi-Fi
and local restaurants which you can find
in any airport but there's something
else one amenity just about everybody
can enjoy
just listen
SFO has what it calls the quiet airport
initiative the airport urges travelers
to use headphones and it strictly limits
the number of overhead announcements
broadcast to the entire terminal
something we noticed while we were there
only the second announcement I've heard
the entire time I've been here and one
of the most popular amenities at SFO is
its water refill stations Travelers go
through 32 500 gallons of water here
each month they can fill up with hot
cold or room temperature water what's
next are you going to start putting some
soda machines or anything else in here
more people now want Perrier or their
Seltzer sparkling water yeah water is
something we're thinking about so yes
wow okay well sparkling water coming to
SFO soon maybe
all of these amenities have helped the
airport receive high marks in customer
satisfaction they placed second in a JD
Power survey which weighs heavily in the
wsj rankings J power looks at six
different factors and it's everything
from check-in you know through security
through shopping and dining and baggage
claim we're talking about the things
that Travelers really interact with once
they get to the air exactly yes I mean
what a lot of us remember about an
airport besides whether our flight was
on time or not that's right because
those amenities are only really
enjoyable to Travelers who aren't angry
about delayed travel but an SFO delays
aren't common it's among the airports
with the highest on-time arrival and
departures rate their on-time arrivals
and departures were both above 80
percent and it wasn't that long ago in
fact it was 2019 in our last survey
where it was 72 percent that's you know
that's a that's a big Improvement for
people still those numbers don't tell
the whole story at SFO travel has yet to
return to what it was before the
pandemic both passenger and flight
volumes are still down more than 25
percent according to airport statistics
the two big International markets out of
San Francisco pre-pandemic were London
and Hong Kong and Hong Kong only just
reopened recently you know to people
without a quarantine so you know that
means less congestion here it helps the
on-time performance for sure is there
any reason to believe that once those
numbers boost back up to a hundred
percent that SFO might have trouble
keeping their High ranks in on-time
arrivals and departures yeah that's
that's the million dollar question but
cetero says he isn't worried we have a
very busy Bank in the morning actually
our morning bank is busier than it was
pre-covered and so I think really the
factors are around larger aircraft
and higher load factors is really what's
helping us and I and I think that's
sustainable San Francisco's top ranking
could be confusing for those just
looking at Price however obviously what
Travelers really care the most about are
ticket prices and San Francisco didn't
fare so well in the value category
compared to nearby San Jose and Oakland
sfo's average ticket prices are higher
27 more than San Jose and 39 more than
Oakland SFO says this is due in part to
lack of competition for travel to some
destinations there's just markets that
are captured markets that that there
isn't the competition in that airfares
will be higher still the combination of
more reliable flights and top-notch
amenities helped SFO overcome its high
prices to give it wsj's top spot and the
airport isn't done upgrading we've been
opening in phases over the last couple
years as we've completed sections of the
terminal we've brought them online and
now we're about 75 percent complete of
course SFO isn't the only airport
updating its space everybody's always
trying to up their game because there's
so much competition especially in this
region so what's it going to take for
San Francisco to be top of the list
again next year they've just got to keep
the momentum going and make sure that
the process is is seamless and hopefully
the congestion stays in check
foreign
[Music]